[Música]
hola bienvenidos a el debate de france
24 soy santiago lópez gonzález el
presidente de estados unidos joe biden
cumplió un año de mandato los retos a
los que se ha visto afrontando allí
desde la casa blanca son múltiples
volver a posicionar a eeuu a nivel
internacional la pandemia de kobe 19 la
financiación estatal para ayudar a
sostener la economía de ese país también
la profunda polarización al interior de
los estados unidos las tensiones
internacionales con rusia con ir a las
discrepancias con china su lejana
relación con américa latina' la
migración por supuesto entre otros
aspectos la redacción de france24 ha
preparado el siguiente informe que nos
sirve para ponernos en contexto de este
primer año del presidente de battenberg
sobre aplicar un año como presidente de
eeuu y un panorama agridulce para joe
biden llegó al cargo con el mandato de
unir al país frenar los embates de la
pandemia y llenar un vacío de liderazgo
tras la era trump
éxitos los hubo consiguió aprobar un
paquete de alivio del hobbit 19 de 19
billones de dólares en marzo impulsando
la vacunación y el testeo masivo también
logró aprobar un ambicioso plan de
infraestructura por un billón de dólares
para renovar las maltrechas carreteras
puentes y tuberías del país ya ha
conseguido bajar el desempleo de cerca
del 9% al 39 por ciento
pero ante el virus tal vez yobái de
encanto victoria antes de tiempo aseguró
que para el 4 de julio día nacional el
país había logrado la independencia ante
el cob y 19 pero semanas más tarde llegó
delta y más recientemente omicron llevó
a nuevos récords de contagio
la fatiga pandémica de los
estadounidenses llegó al límite
una cadena de suministros golpeada dejó
algunas estanterías vacías y la
inflación alcanzó su nivel más alto en
casi 40 años la mirada también estuvo
puesta en la crisis fronteriza con
méxico donde los cruces ilegales también
batieron récord
y a nivel internacional la retirada de
tropas de afganistán en agosto daban fin
a la más larga guerra del país pero
dejaba gravemente dañada la imagen
365 días dejan a biden con una
aprobación en bajada pasando del 56 por
ciento al 42 por ciento de cara a unas
elecciones de medio término en las que
los votantes podrían arrebatarle el
estrecho control de las cámaras a los
demócratas va a ir de aena hecho de la
aprobación de su proyecto de gasto
social y de la defensa del derecho al
voto sus nuevos caballos de batalla un
año de retos pero también de grandes
progresos así lo definió baiden en su
más reciente rueda de prensa un
presidente en problemas pero que ha
recordado que su trabajo no ha terminado
hay varias encuestas que muestran y
reflejan el descontento la desaprobación
por parte de los ciudadanos algunas
marcan el 54 por ciento de los
ciudadanos de estados unidos están
desaprobando la gestión del presidente
by den también hay otras que indican que
el 43 si apoya el trabajo realizado en
estos 12 meses habló de resultados que
coinciden o están bastante similares a
encuestas que fueron realizadas en el
pasado mes de octubre lo que refleja una
variación prácticamente mínima en cuanto
a la opinión en torno al presidente de
eeuu el balance del primer año del
presidente jobvite en un año de
frustraciones de logros de metas por
cumplir ese es nuestro tema de debate
hoy en france 24 y para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a mariel y lópez
santana ella es catedrática asociada y
directora del programa graduado de
ciencias políticas del sar school of
policy and government en george mason
university también está con nosotros
bueno es esta también con nosotros otro
de nuestros invitados he perdido el
nombre acá el cox alomar él es
constitucionalista es profesor de
derecho de la universidad del distrito
de columbia en la ciudad de washington
la capital de estados unidos ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
dejar todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas en torno a este tema a través
de las redes sociales de recuerdo cuáles
son estamos en facebook en instagram y
en twitter no se encuentran como arroba
france24
s y arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal también del área de internet me
recuerdan que hay una encuesta numeral
encuesta efe 24 y pueden participar
dejar su respuesta en torno a esta
pregunta que les estamos haciendo yo
baiden cumple un año como presidente de
eeuu cree que la gestión del mandatario
se caracteriza por sus a aciertos y
errores dejen todos sus comentarios aquí
a través de las redes sociales comienzo
rápidamente con mariel y en eeuu para
abrir este debate quiero comenzar
marieli
el balance general su opinión en líneas
generales de la gestión del presidente
para detener a lo largo de este año y
por supuesto bienvenida al programa
muchas gracias por la invitación bueno
primero nada yo quiero decir que en uno
de los aciertos de la presidencia de
dwight
ciertamente ha sido cambiar el tono
sobre la pandemia verdad bajo trump
sabemos que trump muchas veces negó a
una existencia de la pandemia y el daño
que estaba haciendo en la vida de las
personas y las muertes y todo lo que
tuvo que ver con eso en lo que tiene que
ver con eso sin embargo ya vemos que por
ejemplo desde que bailén empezó en la
presidencia pues sí ha reafirmado la
importancia del efecto de la pandemia en
las vidas de las personas en la economía
etcétera
de esa manera pienso que eso ciertamente
ha sido uno de los aciertos
la residencia de baile en términos
rafael pasó a preguntarle lo mismo este
balance para conocer sus opiniones y sus
posturas en torno a este año este primer
año de gobierno del presidente parten en
eeuu y bienvenido al programa cuáles
opiniones
no gracias por la invitación este ha
sido un año sumamente difícil sumamente
complejo para el presidente de byd en
los resultados sumamente lentos y yo
creo que el problema fundamental el
desafío fundamental de bailén ha sido la
división interna la fragmentación
interna dentro del propio partido
demócrata
tanto en el senado como en la cámara de
representantes lo que ha hecho imposible
que él haya podido cumplir con algunas
de sus promesas programáticas el vil
back better vil y quedó en nada en el
senado todavía no se ha atendido a
asuntos importantísimos con respecto a
los derechos electorales de los
ciudadanos norteamericanos no se ha
entendido no se han atendido asuntos
fundamentales con respecto a la
inmigración a la reforma migratoria hay
una inflación altísima hay unos desafíos
pero desafíos estructurales porque la
agenda de él está atascada en el
congreso a pesar de que los demócratas
controlan cámara y senado así que un
presidente un poco gente ante la
infraestructura política de su propio
partido por eso entonces lo que ha
propendido deja que haya una valoración
un poco negativa de su gestión y de que
todavía no se vean resultados concretos
y que haya un poco de desesperación y yo
creo que eso es lo que están arrojando
las encuestas
rafael usted menciona un tema muy
importante un tema doméstico y es la
polarización que hay en la sociedad de
eeuu quiero comenzar con este tema
quiero comenzar con temas
domésticos temas que le conciernen a la
sociedad de eeuu y al interior de este
país antes de hablar de los temas
internacionales ya que usted lo menciona
continuó con usted
ha comenzado algún tipo de mejoría en
cuanto a esta polarización usted qué
opinión tiene si esto se mantiene si
esto se ha profundizado si ha dado
algunos pasos la administración bailén
para comenzar a cerrar esta brecha que
mostró evidentemente con los resultados
de las elecciones en donde bardem salió
como ganador y presidente que había
prácticamente dos ópticas completamente
distintas la percepción que tienen los
ciudadanos de lo que ellos conciben como
eeuu
no precisamente todavía no no hay signos
de que haya habido una convergencia a lo
interno del partido demócrata
todavía el senador joe manchin de
western y ni anda por un camino y el
presidente by den por otro y todavía en
la cámara de representantes el ala
liberal del partido demócrata
no está contenta del todo con la gestión
de bailén ahí
impaciencia ante lo que se percibe como
lentitud fíjense que en el senado se
derrotó la iniciativa de los aliados del
presidente para acabar con la figura del
filibusterismo y un poco destrancar el
escenario en el senado fíjense que es en
esa iniciativa de los aliados de bailén
de shock sumar líder de la mayoría
demócrata fracasó hace apenas unos días
así que todavía no se visualiza no se
ven en el escenario las convergencias
las concertaciones importantes que
tienen que darse para que la agenda al
presidente baile entonces pueda
concretarse en el congreso
mariel y retomar la conexión con usted
su opinión sobre este tema de la
polarización que marca a la sociedad de
eeuu los ejemplos son múltiples de lo
que hemos visto a lo largo de este año
pero cuál es su percepción opinión sobre
este tema
sí estoy muy de acuerdo con lo que dijo
el profesor aunque de cierta manera
vemos que la brecha entre los
republicanos y los demócratas se hace
aún más grande sobre todo con la
posibilidad de que trump vuelva a correr
para la presidencia vemos que los
republicanos siguen votando como un
bloque y siguen tratando de bloquear
todo lo que los demócratas tratan de
pasar y ya como mencionó el profesor
corts pues tenemos la figura de man
singh que tiende a es el lado de los
republicanos en esos temas y después si
llamamos muchos de los temas que son
tradicionalmente lo que diferencia a los
republicanos a los demócratas por
ejemplo si debemos seguir aumentando el
gasto pues vemos que ahí existe aún esa
brecha que puede ser política pero
también es parte de la base del partido
y si nos por ejemplo nos referimos a el
tema de
los derechos del voto y cuáles debe ser
el rol de los estados
y el oid federal pues también vemos esa
brecha entre los republicanos y los
demócratas
demócratas que favorecen de que haya más
centralización más poder al gobierno
federal y sin embargo los republicanos
dentro de su plataforma cristina después
favorecen que los estados sean los que
dominen esos temas ya sea desde las
máscaras
a
asuntos de voto
marielis con este panorama que usted
explica y con lo que dice rafael en
torno al tema de la polarización como
visualiza usted y analiza los tres años
siguientes que le restan al presidente
de bailén con este tema de la
polarización política y de la sociedad
las opiniones dentro de los
estadounidenses están también muy
divididas muy parciales y muy bien
marcadas entre dos en perspectivas muy
distintas esto entonces nos indica tres
años muy complejos para el presidente
que piensa usted
perdí la conexión marielis bueno vamos a
retomar entonces a solucionar el tema
técnico que tenemos con su audio para
repetir de esta pregunta y pasó entonces
hacerle esta pregunta de este análisis a
rafael que con el panorama que ustedes
explican y el análisis que ustedes dos
dan sobre el tema de la polarización en
eeuu como ven ustedes los tres años que
resta de gobierno porque es que todavía
falta mucho tiempo para que el
presidente bailen y deje la casa blanca
si es que así sucede si no es reelecto
van a ser tres años entonces muy
difíciles para la política interna cuál
es su opinión
sumamente difícil es yo creo que lo que
resta de camino va a ser más complejo
porque nos avecina moza una lección de
medio término en donde se va a
recomponer el senado y la cámara
completa es decir es posible que cámara
y senado pasen a manos republicanas cabe
la posibilidad de aquí a apenas diez
meses y tienen el otro escenario en el
otro resorte que es el tribunal supremo
a los eeuu un tribunal compuesto de
nueve jueces pero que ideológicamente
parecería que hay una mayoría de seis
jueces conservadores y tres jueces
liberales hay tres jueces en ese
tribunal supremo que fueron nominados
por el presidente trump y confirmados
por el senado de mitch mcconnell y que
ya usted vio en el caso de la vacuna
hace unos días resolvieron en contra de
la postura del presidente de bailén así
que no solamente el presidente de bailén
tiene un desafío con respecto a la
composición del congreso sino que tiene
un desafío permanente con respecto a la
composición del tribunal supremo que
como usted sabe en los eeuu es el más
alto foro judicial es el intérprete
máximo de la constitución así que los
desafíos que se ciernen sobre badén son
enorme y todavía no hemos empezado a
hablar del tema internacional ya vamos a
hablar de los desafíos internacionales
rafael por supuesto lo tengo aquí en mi
agenda para analizarlo con ustedes
marielis creo que ya retomamos la
comunicación con usted avanzó con otro
de los temas que tengo esa relación con
el congreso una relación que ya ustedes
han explicado ha sido muy difícil ha
habido muchas discrepancias al
presidente no le han favorecido en
muchas de las votaciones y en el aval de
su de algunos de sus proyectos pero si
bien en las elecciones de medio término
esto complica entonces vuelvo a la
pregunta inicial tres años que se vienen
muy complejos entonces para bailén ya lo
decía rafael muy difíciles entonces
si seguimos la indicación de lo que pasó
en el estado de virginia verdad que hubo
un cambio a mano de republicanos pues
todo parece indicar que va a ser muy
cuesta arriba para los demócratas
mantener el poder ya sea a nivel del
congreso pero también si pensamos a
nivel de los estados verdad y lo que
mucha gente le molesta le preocupa al
respecto es cómo eso puede impactar
directamente las vidas de las personas
es que nos está yendo con la pandemia
por ejemplo la diferencia entre los
republicanos y los demócratas cuando
vienen a los mandatos de las máscaras de
las escuelas verdad así que en ese
sentido pues cuando existen unas
decisiones que son tan polarizadas pues
entonces eso definitivamente va a
afectar la manera en que la gente va a
votar en el futuro y ciertamente va a
ser un gran
reto para bailén mucho expectativa en
torno a esas elecciones de medio término
y en eeuu puede cambiar por completo el
panorama político y la gestión del
presidente de byd en para lo que resta
de su mandato de cara a la nueva
conformación que tenga el congreso en
ese país paso a otro tema importante de
la agenda la pandemia de kobe 19 un
manejo de la pandemia completamente
diferente a lo que venía haciendo el
presidente en su momento el presidente
de donald trump un manejo completamente
distinto también en cuanto al
relacionamiento que ha tenido eeuu con
los organismos de salud internacional
perspectivas y opiniones rafael en torno
al manejo de la pandemia la vacunación e
incentivar a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses para que se inoculen
para evitar el avance de la pandemia que
vemos que en este momento la variante
omicron está causando estragos allí con
un y alto nivel de contagio y comenzando
a tener altas ocupaciones los hospitales
en los diferentes estados
bueno la estrategia de bailén ha sido
mucho más proactiva mucho más agresiva
que la del expresidente trump lo que
sucede es que a mí a mi modo de ver las
cosas el presidente baile me parece a mí
que ha subestimado la oposición que se
ha venido generando a nivel de los
estados y de los gobernadores
republicanos
y fíjense que el presidente de bailén se
enfrascó en una lucha legal
con los gobernadores republicanos que lo
llevaron al tribunal y fíjese usted que
el presidente de bailén acaba de perder
el caso ante el tribunal suprema de los
estados unidos que ha dicho que el
presidente no tenía el poder para a
través de la agencia o sea ordenar la
vacunación en las empresas privadas de
la manera que lo había hecho así que de
nuevo
el tribunal supremo le le envía la
limpia le tira la bola como dice la papa
caliente al congreso para que sea el
congreso el que actúe lo que pasa que en
el congreso en el senado los
republicanos tienen una fuerza muy
importante que también se oponen al
presidente de bailén así que 9 la mente
vemos un discurso distinto vemos un
discurso más agresivo pero vemos una
oposición fuerte que se enquista a
través de los tribunales y de las
legislaturas estatales para hacerle la
contra el presidente de bailén y dentro
de ese escenario lo que se genera mucho
incertidumbre que eso es lo que se ve en
las encuestas no mucha incertidumbre
mucha impaciencia de parte del público
con la gestión del presidente bailar
marjal y es que tanto esta oposición que
menciona rafael ha sido oposición
política o ha sido simplemente oposición
por hacer oposición y estar en contra de
las propuestas que hace el presidente y
si el presidente valencia ha hecho una
lectura correcta de ese sentir de la
sociedad de eeuu en cuanto a lo que se
debe hacer para contrarrestar los
efectos de la pandemia de kobe 19 es
positivo es negativo usted como lo ve y
lo pregunto por por por este sentimiento
de este valor de la libertad que tanto
profesa eeuu a nivel internacional pero
donde hay muchas discrepancias entre
quienes se quieren vacunar los que no lo
quieren hacer
rafael lo menciona las discrepancias con
los con los gobernadores por ver una
óptica completamente distinta está el
presidente haciendo una lectura bien a
nivel nacional de la situación
yo creo que
de cierta manera
bailén se mandó un mensaje muy rápido de
que la pandemia estábamos a punto de
terminar la pandemia eso fue en el
verano y al pasar eso eso hizo que la
brecha que existía entre la gente que se
quiere vacunar los que no se quieren
vacunar lo que existe creen que la
pandemia es un problema los que creen
que la pandemia no es un problema y eso
lo que ha pasado es que ha en el largo
plazo pues le salió mal la jugada porque
cuando ahora estamos en diciembre enero
y llegar omicron pues pues la gente no
está preparada y sobre todos aquellos
que él no cree y no creen en la pandemia
que no quieren usar máscara que no
quieren ponerse la vacuna pues usan esa
oportunidad
políticamente por ejemplo vemos el
gobernador de virginia que recién
recientemente tiene ese mensaje
explotarlo políticamente porque pues
sabemos las si nos referimos a la
ciencia y como tal vemos todos los
ejemplos de por ejemplo como la usar la
máscara por ese beneficioso para
mantener las escuelas abiertas etcétera
etcétera pero vemos algunos gobernantes
y también público que utilizan este tipo
de mensaje para explotar
negativamente los escenarios que el que
tenemos ahora
en eeuu para terminar este capítulo de
temas de política interna quiero cerrar
con la economía un tema importante el
gobierno ha dado una gran cantidad
millones de dólares para ayudar a las
empresas a los medianos y pequeños
comerciantes para mantenerse a flote por
el cierre de las economías durante los
confinamientos también sacó un as bajo
la manga y ese ese plan de
infraestructura con el que le espera
reactivar la plena capacidad la economía
además un plan completamente necesario
para seguir siendo competitivos a nivel
internacional perspectivas marielis en
todo al tema económico le ha funcionado
el presidente de estas estas jugadas
haciendo frente a la crisis que estamos
viviendo
yo creo que es ciertamente uno de los
aciertos de la gobernanza del presidente
de baire ha sido todos los paquetes que
ha podido pasar verdad toda la ayuda del
desempleo todos los ayudas que vinieron
con ataques claret que recientemente
terminó y todas otras ayudas que ya
sabemos verdad ha sido trascendental sin
embargo como sabemos
existe un gran
discurso de que tales ayudas por lo
tanto ha llevado a la inflación que
entonces a largo plazo han afectado
negativamente el presidente verdad
porque los los costos siguen aumentando
y muchos han puesto en la mesa esa idea
de que ha sido a partir de todas esas
ayudas sin embargo tenemos que tomar en
cuenta que el desempleo está bajo
bajísimo hasta casi 4% el país está
creciendo
por otro lado tenemos ese problema de la
inflación que no hay que hay que
reiterar que no es solamente por las
ayudas hay muchas otras razones que han
llevado a la inflación por lo tanto hay
algunos elementos que están fuera de las
manos directamente de presidente y aún
del senado del congreso etcétera claro
entre ellos las fallas en la cadena de
suministros a nivel global eso afectaba
a todos los países rafael su opinión por
el tema económico lo que ha hecho el
presidente a lo largo de esta gestión
pero es una gente inconclusa el
presidente todavía tiene que atender el
tema de la inflación eso significa que
tiene que manejar con mucho tino el tema
de las tasas de interés eso significa
que tiene que manejar con mucho tino la
propuesta de reforma contributiva a
nivel federal y eso significa que el
paquete de medidas que quedó trunco en
el senado ese paquete de medidas que
tenía que ver con asuntos de
beneficiencia social para poder alegar
la crisis de la hiperinflación ese
paquete tiene que retomarse y esas
iniciativas deberían de renegociar se y
el presidente debería de poder pasar un
paquete quizás más modesto pero como
quiera es importante para atender los
desafíos que presupone la hiper la
inflación el tema de los altos costos
que en resumidas cuentas van a afectar a
los menos que tienen claro pasemos ahora
a los temas internacionales
una de las promesas del presidente va a
tener a reposicionar a eeuu en la escena
internacional recuperar eso aliados que
perdieron
eeuu perdió a nivel internacional entre
ellos la unión europea
y otros países del continente asiático
como ven ustedes ese plan de
reposicionamiento es eeuu otra vez ese
país importante en la escena los actores
internacionales vuelven a creer en este
país como un socio importante y
estratégico en materia inter militar
comercial y de defensa de los derechos
humanos y los valores democráticos son
marielis comienzo con usted
sí yo creo que ciertamente ha habido un
cambio bastante importante si lo
comparamos con trump que por ejemplo
dejaba en medio de una reunión y se
regresa a los eeuu verdad en cierta
manera declaró la pandemia tampoco se ha
creado la posibilidad de que vayan a
podido viajar mucho y reunirse con
diferentes tipos de líderes claro está
pero si vemos por ejemplo
desde el punto de vista ambiental de que
el estado son los estados unidos vuelven
a ser parte de ciertos tratados de que
han
participado en ciertos tipos de foros en
la unión europea etcétera
eso sí ciertamente es un indicio de que
vamos en la dirección que debemos ir y
también yo creo que en cierta manera es
un buen indicio de que ya no llevemos
tanto sobre rusia como era en el pasado
con trump que claro está no no sabemos
exactamente qué es lo que está pasando
porque hay otros tipos de
eventos que están pasando entre rusia y
sus vecinos pero ciertamente pienso
porque se ha establecido un poco las
relaciones de eeuu con el resto del
mundo bueno pero si hay una relación
tensa en este momento en la relación
washington moscú por el tema de ucrania
también dejando washington un poco de
lado a bruselas a la unión europea que
es un reclamo que hacen los europeos en
rafael su opinión a eeuu regreso a la
sen internacional vemos estas
discrepancias que mencionó con moscú
pero también vemos la muy criticada
retirada de las tropas
de eeuu de territorio de afganistán y
siguen las tensiones con irán y siguen
las tensiones con china sobre todo
mire eeuu regresó a la mesa
internacional era impostergable del
punto de vista de los intereses
geopolíticos norteamericanos regresar a
la mesa lo que pasa que eeuu ha
regresado a la mesa en un momento
histórico totalmente distinto en un
momento histórico en donde china ya le
ha perdido el respeto a los eeuu en
donde china se ve a sí misma como una
potencia en donde rusia está de nuevo
sacando los tentáculos de la rush
imperial de los zares de los romanos y
se quiere posicionar también por derecho
propio en el escenario internacional en
otras palabras los eeuu si vuelven a la
mesa pero en un escenario sumamente
adverso en donde sus rivales
geopolíticos
básicamente están actuando con impunidad
en este momento estamos a días
posiblemente que rusia invadió ucrania
ayer para sorpresa del mundo para
sorpresa del mundo inclusive para
sorpresa de los propios ucranianos el
presidente de bailén admitió en una
conferencia de prensa
que estamos a muy poco tiempo de que
putin invada efectivamente a ucrania
sobre supondría una crisis horrible para
la otan
para la unión europea pero
fundamentalmente para la otan y para los
eeuu del punto de vista estratégico y si
rusia puede con impunidad anexar a
ucrania pues imagínense usted lo que va
a ser china con taiwán y solo crea una
serie de interrogantes
dificilísimas a los eeuu con respecto a
su rol en el mundo con respecto a la
santidad de sus alianzas con sus aliados
va a defender los estados un lado sus
aliados en esta coyuntura va a permitir
que putin a la hitler anexe sus vecinos
y sin hacer nada impunemente esas son
preguntas bien difíciles está eeuu
listos para meterse en una guerra con
rusia en esta coyuntura con la
hiperinflación con la crisis del cob y
con la crisis política con la
balcanización ideológica a lo interno de
los estados unidos se pregunta sumamente
difíciles para el presidente va a ir en
esta coyuntura y volvería a abrir otros
frentes que ya tiene eeuu en marcha como
diferencia centro en moscú y washington
pero se enfrentan en territorios como
siria por ejemplo en donde pues estas
dos perspectivas del mundo están en
terreno enfrentadas en ese país que hay
de la relación con américa latina'
marjal es una relación que muchos países
de américa latina- reclaman que ha sido
muy muy fría muy lejana muy distante
vemos a washington solamente
relacionándose cercanamente con países
de centroamérica por el tema migratorio
y con méxico por los temas comerciales
que tienen en marcha como ve usted la
relación si ciertamente yo creo que
bailén ha tenido como lo dice muy poca
relación con los países latinoamericanos
donde van más vemos que ha jugado un rol
es todo el tema de la del asunto
migratorio verdad es sobre centroamérica
médico si abre las fronteras y deja que
las personas puedan
a solicitar su entrada en los eeuu y
etcétera por lo tanto
ciertamente como usted ha dicho las
relaciones con latinoamérica
en generales han sido bastante frías sin
tomar en consideración las relaciones
con puerto rico que ha sido un poco
diferente rafael su opinión sobre el
tema de la relación con américa latina'
grow presidente bailén ha sido mucho
menos arrojado que el presidente obama
evidentemente él no va a actuar con
respecto a cuba en esta coyuntura tal
parece que ese no es un tema prioritario
para él en este momento tiene demasiados
otros asuntos en su plato el tema de
venezuela tampoco lo ha tocado ni
siquiera el tema de nicaragua el
presidente de byd en sí ha tenido como
usted surgir una relación en
centroamérica todavía un poco pre un
poco
en cierta verdad porque las iniciativas
que se anunciaron con mucha fuego sida
al comienzo pues realmente no se han
concretado y con respecto al resto del
conosur y demás pues tampoco ha habido
grandes iniciativas así que el
presidente va a ir en sin embargo en la
coyuntura con rusia se va a ver forzado
a / a tener una relación más intensa con
la américa latina porque china y rúsia
si tienen en agenda
involucrarse más activamente en la
américa latina a mí me parece que eso va
a forzar a que los estados unidos asuman
un rol más importante de interlocutores
constructivos en la américa latina
porque de lo contrario ese vacío lo va a
llenar china y lo vayan a rusia que ya
lo está llenando en materia comercial
para algunos países de américa latina-
su principal socio comercial ya no es
eeuu que hace el vecino sino china me
queda un minuto para la conclusión
marielis que sigue entonces para el
presidente de byd en en estos tres años
sí yo creo que el gran reto de bailén va
a poder ser a tratar de pasar esos
pequeños paquetes que pueden dejar un
gran legado sobre su presidencia a nivel
de la política social si por ejemplo
puede pasar todo esto que tiene que ver
con los con la ayuda a las familias los
niños
etcétera etcétera marielis y para el
cierre también habrá reelección de
bailén ya si trump decide correr yo creo
que
rafael también su conclusión de lo que
viene para el presidente bailen en estos
tres años y si puede haber reelección de
él y de kamala harris en la casa blanca
pues yo creo que es sumamente prematuro
hablar de lo que va a pasar en el 2024
fíjese que clinton tuvo un año inicial
horrible en el 93 y ganó reelección en
el 96 y truman tuvo un año horrible
cuando llegó e inicialmente 45 46 y
luego ganó el 48 la reelección aquí la
política es el arte de lo posible es
sumamente incierto lo que pueda suceder
así que un poco más de tiempo pues a
rafael cox ya maría liz lópez santana
les agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros haber hecho el análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 sobre este tema
ustedes puede seguir dejando sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través de
las redes sociales y por supuesto los
invito para que sigan en sintonía de
france 24
[Música]